hello grammarians welcome to the last
and strangest part of the irregular verb
the truly irregular yes friends here I
have compiled all the weirdest oh the
wiliest all the eeriest and spookiest
forms of verbs that don't otherwise fall
into other categories so we can't say
that they end with a changed
edie we can't say that they end with an
en and we can't say that there's a vowel
shift we've already covered those this
is the time for the weird stuff first up
ugh t oh what a strange collection of
letters that is to be found in English
so we take a word like teach and in the
past tense it's taught likewise catch
becomes caught and bring becomes brought
yes that's really strange there are only
a couple of words that behave that way
it's also pretty weird and pretty rare
for there to be a vowel shift from the
present to the past and also it does
sound so for example we take the word
flee which means to run away and in the
past it's fled likewise in the present
we say say and in the past we say said
so that a becomes a and that he becomes
a and it's this weird vowel shift that's
also followed up by a dis out there are
some words for whom time does not exist
these are verbs for whom the present
tense is the same as the past tense
prepare to have your mind blown the past
tense of bet is bet the past tense of
set is set the past tense of hurt is
hurt yeah it's weird
finally there are some helper verbs or
auxiliary verbs called modal's that are
super weird and have these properties
that aren't repeated anywhere else in
English so present tense can be comes
past tense could I can stand on my head
or I could stand on my head when I was 5
may becomes might in the past
shall be comes should and will be comes
would and what's super weird about these
elves and could should or would is
listen to me saying them you don't
pronounce the ELLs and this is the only
place in English where that silent L
shows up it's so strange ah I love it
these are the irregular verbs and these
in fact are the most irregular of the
irregular if you can master these you
will be a grammar champion and I believe
in you because you can learn anything
Dave it out